Auch der Rasenfunk sagt jetzt mal ordentlich Schalke. Die Königsblauen sind Zweitligameister und kehren in die Bundesliga zurück. Doch wer folgt Schalke nach oben? Und für welchen Club neben Preußen Münster, wie wir jetzt wissen, endet die Saison im Abstieg? All das, was ihr vor dem letzten Spieltag der 2. Bundesliga der Männer wissen müsst, bespreche ich nun mit Eva-Lotta Bohle. Let's go!
Schon im Programm? Der Rasenfunk.
Langeheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und aufs Bug ist oben! Rossi zu kurz ab wäre lang genug für Willi Landgraf. Wagner, Martin Wagner.
Und das 1 zu 0. Markus Kort aus dem Gewühl.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Ja, und halt ein ausgeglichenes Torverhältnis. Also als einzige da unten drin, eben keine negativ. Ich würde tatsächlich noch ein bisschen widersprechen, weil ja, Dresden hatte Spielkontrolle, aber ich finde, du konntest eben schon von Anfang an so ein bisschen merken. Also ich habe es in der Konferenz geguckt, to be fair. Aber dass man schon irgendwie so ein bisschen wusste, ha, Braunschweig muss schon mehr machen. Und ich fand dann schon, dass gerade nach dem 1-0, dass die Reaktion dann noch nicht so ganz da war. Also wirklich erst mit dem zweiten Gegentor. Und ich fand da fast ironisch, vom Spielverlauf her und von dem, was Dresden investiert hat, fast tatsächlich dann parallel zur Hinrunde. Weil auch in der Hinrunde hatten wir immer wieder Spiele, wo wir– Dresden war ja nie richtig, richtig schlecht. Wir haben da einfach immer nur gesagt, es fehlt einfach die Zweiliga-Qualität im Kader. Und wenn wir da mal gucken, das Spiel gegen Braunschweig in der Hinrunde, hat man eben 2 zu 3 verloren, nach 2 zu 0 Führung von Braunschweig. Das Spiel gegen Kiel hat man auch verloren. Das wäre so ein bisschen was, ich unterschreibe das, dass ich auch glaube, dass sie am Ende in der Liga bleiben. Einfach aufgrund der Umstände. Aber ich fand jetzt nicht, dass man sagen konnte, man geht aus diesem Spiel raus und sagt so, ja gut, das war dann einfach nur Pech bei Dresden. Also ich fand das schon…
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Also nicht nur Pech, sondern ich fand nämlich schon, dass ich finde am Ende des Tages trotzdem in dem Spiel weniger Argumente, die für einen Dresden-Sieg gesprochen hätten. Also und wir wissen, Braunschweig, die sind momentan einfach nur auf Kurs. Wir brauchen den Sieg, der Rest ist uns gerade relativ wumpe. So, ne, hat Anna ja auch schon gesagt, also man kann, der Sieg gegen Lautern von Braunschweig war so eine Kategorie, naja, Arbeit, für Fußballspielen. Aber ja, also das fand ich so ein bisschen… Also da hat man sich selber so ein bisschen ins Ausgespielt zwischendurch in der Partie, dass man kann dann natürlich auch darüber diskutieren, also ich bin auch team, kein Kommentar bei Stefan Kutschke sonst, ob das auch ehrlich gesagt, also dafür geht es für Dynamo noch um zu viel, als dass man Kutschke dann da so reinbringt und ja klar, er macht hinter das 2-1, aber der kann halt auch in beide Richtungen ausschlagen als Pendel, ja, also…
Ja gut, macht den Elfmeter nicht… Mich hat es auch gewundert, dass eben nicht da ferner eingewechselt wurde. Ich glaube, dann geht es bei Kutschke wirklich um… Also egal, was man von diesem Menschen hält, der hat ja eine Führungsstärke in diesem Kader. Und dann geht es eher glaube ich darum, jemanden auf Sage zu schicken, der sich da, wie sagt man so schön, nichts scheißt und allein das soll dann auf die Kollegen abfärben. Tatsächlich finde ich den Punkt ganz gut, was du gesagt hast mit dem Vergleich zur Hinrunde und da kann man ja eben oft daher zu sagen, da fehlt die Qualität. Das passt insofern zu diesem Spiel, weil Julian Pauli in der Innenverteidigung gefehlt hatte und dann hat sich auch noch Thomas Keller in der 1. Halbzeit so verletzt, dass dann Claudio Kammerknecht reinkam. Fünf Minuten später, also fünf Minuten nach Wiedernfeld, fällt er dann noch das 2 zu 0. Also da sind wir dann auch bei teilweise einem endigen Spieler in der Defensive vor allem gefehlt und das merkst du diesem Kader sofort an, weil der zweite Anzug halt nicht so gut ist. Also das ist dann vielleicht die Brücke, die man schlagen kann. Apropos Brücke schlagen, ich würde fast sagen, wenn wir schon in dem Quartier sind, dann gehen wir doch über, weil sonst wird das irgendwie so ein wenig flüssiger Übergang. Dann sind wir nicht mehr Eintracht Braunschweig und ich würde das unterschreiben, was du sagst, dass es jetzt nicht nur Pech war bei Dresden. Ich fand halt nur Dresden nicht wirklich schlecht. Ich fand halt Braunschweig irgendwie in ihrer Spielanlage nur noch überzeugender, denn man hat sich ja schon für Lars Kornetka entschieden, weil der auch irgendwie etwas mit Ball entwickeln soll und auch ein bisschen besser und schöner und stringenter spielen lassen soll. Alte Zahneiner Backhaus. Das war ja schon eines der Ziele. Aber du bist natürlich irgendwann in einer Saison an dem Punkt. Du hast es eben erwähnt. Anna hat es erwähnt. Punkte, Punkte, Punkte, Punkte. Und in dem Spiel, finde ich, hat Lars Kornetka bewiesen, dass der Gegendenball auch richtig gut kann. Also das war ein Spiel, wo ich das Gefühl hatte, das muss man sehr viel an ihm festmachen. Der hat zum einen den Move gebracht, fünf neue zu bringen. Fünf neue Spieler hat vor dem Spiel gesagt, er möchte eine neue Energie und Leichtigkeit reinbringen. Und ich finde, ein Schlüsselspieler in dem Sinne war Kaufmann. Fabio Kaufmann, die alte Braunschweig-Legende, der seit einem Jahr, glaube ich, hat der Kommentator gesagt, nicht mehr in der Startelf stand und in der Saison keine Rolle gespielt hat. Da sind wir mal ehrlich, also er kam ab und zu als, er kam vorher 15 Mal rein als Einwechsespieler. Und den hat er von Anfang an gebracht und weil er wusste, wir brauchen jetzt Jungs, die kennen diesen Abschießkampf. Und in diesem Spiel hat sich dann eine Achse von Spielern herausgebildet, die einfach sich, denen war das so alles egal. Und die haben diesen Druck so getrotzt und diese Truppe so zusammengehalten und es war die Achse Hoffmann im Tor, Lino Tempelmann im Mittelfeld und dann eben Fabio Kaufmann auf der Außenbahn mit deren Erfahrung auch im Abstiegskampf. Die haben das ja auch schon mit Braunschweig ein, zwei Mal mitgemacht, haben die dieses sehr Aufopferungs- und disziplinierte Spiel gegen den Ball angeführt. Braunschweig war kantig, die waren eklig, die haben den Fuß draufgehalten, die haben dadurch auch Dynamos Spielfluss immer wieder zerstört, haben aber auch im 4-4-2 gegen den Ball die Ketten super eng gemacht. Also Dynamo hatte es sehr schwer. Das war jetzt nicht nur eben dieses Heiner Backhaus. Wir müssen ekliger sein, sondern es war auch intelligent im Spiel gegen den Ball. Ich fand, man hat es geschafft, vor allem in der ersten Halbzeit, Dynamo das eigene Spiel aufzudrücken. Und ja, dann lebt das auch ein Stück weit von Glück, dass man dann diese beiden Tore macht, denn man hat ja nicht viel produziert. Dann gilt es, in diesen Momenten da zu sein. Am ersten Tor war ja Tempelmann zum Beispiel beteiligt, weil er diesen Ball da ist, in den 16er führt. Und dann ist Flick beim zweiten Ball da, zack, 1-0. Und beim 2-0 ist es dann ja Fabio Kaufmann, der die Flanke schlägt in die Mitte. Also dann sind diese Spieler da, und das sind halt Spieler, die wissen aus den letzten Jahren, wir brauchen diesen eingeheulene Moment, und dann müssen wir da sein, und das waren sie. Deswegen fand ich, das war für den Zustand von Braunschweig und für die Situation in der Tabelle und so weiter, war das ein blitzsauberes Heimspiel. Das wird sich nicht so angefühlt haben, besonders nach dem 2-1 Gegentreffer. Wie gesagt, du hättest auch Argumente für eine Punkteteilung definitiv finden können. Aber du hast dieses Spiel, du hast es erzwungen. Natürlich hält Ron Torbenhoffmann in diesem Spiel einen Elfmeter. Natürlich ist der da. Also das hat irgendwie in dieses Spiel gepasst, und ich fand's imponierend, wie Braunschweig aufgetreten ist. Das hat man diese Saison nicht so oft gesehen, weil es eine Mischung aus Wille und Cleverness war. Das fehlte oft. Und deswegen ist das ein Heimsieg, der irgendwie in Ordnung geht. Und letztendlich dazu führen könnte, dass man in der Liga bleibt, zeigt gleich. Um das einmal einzubinden, muss man eben sagen, Braunschweig steht mit 37 Punkten auf Rang 14. Das ist ein einziger Punkt Abstand zum Religationsrang. Und du spielst jetzt auswärts auf Schalke, die sich gut verabschieden wollen zu Hause. Ja, herzlichen Glückwunsch. Also, das könnte schwierig sein.
Genau, und weil das ist nämlich mein einziges Problem, dass Braunschweig immer wieder diese Spiele zwischendurch drin hat, wo du eben siehst, was möglich ist unter Kornetka. Und dann hast du aber zwischendurch wieder diese Niederlage gegen Kiel drin. Ja?
Ja, ja, ja.
Und das wäre so was. Und dann, wie du schon sagst, Schalke. Also ich meine, man kann auch sagen, vielleicht haben sie auch genau deshalb letzte Woche auf Ibiza verbracht, weil sie gewusst haben, ja gut, wenn wir das jetzt die Woche vor dem Braunschweig-Spiel machen, dann gibt es irgendwie, da klopfen minimum 5 Vereine an und sagen, sag mal, habt ihr eigentlich irgendwie einen Schuss nicht mehr gehört? So. Und da muss man sagen, das ist halt, wo ich Braunschweig halt am Ende noch nicht diese vollständige Stabilität einräumen würde. Und Schalke ist halt einfach die beste Heimmannschaft der Liga. Und dafür ist einfach, hat man leider, also man teilt sich mit Düsseldorf eben, man muss sagen, immer noch ein katastrophales Torverhältnis von minus 17. Ja. Das heißt und klar, Bielefeld hat einen Punkt weniger, führt, würde ich jetzt mal mit minus 22 aus dieser Verrechnung ein bisschen rausnehmen. Aber wenn es beispielsweise am Ende darum geht, um Dresden, um Magdeburg und Bielefeld als die drei Konkurrenz, gut, Düsseldorf wird jetzt mal ausgenommen, dann stehst du da leider immer noch torverhältnismäßig am schlechtesten da. Und das liegt unter anderem natürlich dann auch daran, dass du eben, wie gesagt, keine vollständige Konstanz drin hattest, auch in den letzten Leistungen. Also Formtabelle Platz 12 ist halt wirklich das absolute Nirgendwo. Oder was ist denn so eine Formtabelle? Doch, Platz 10, Entschuldigung.
Am Ende stimmt halt irgendwie beides. Man will sich die Emotionswelt in Braunschweig nicht vorstellen ohne diesen Sieg. Stell dir mal vor, du verlierst das. Dann brennt es offensichtlich mehr, weil dann bist du punktgleich mit Firt. Und dann gehen die Lichter wirklich aus auf Schalke. So kannst du dir jetzt sagen, wir haben es in der eigenen Hand. Wenn wir was Verrücktes machen gegen Schalke, dann kann es das keiner nehmen. Und wir dürfen auch Selbstvertrauen aus diesem Spiel gegen Dresden nehmen. Zeitgleich stimmt absolut das, was du sagst. Es wird brutal schwer auf Schalke. Schalke will sich mit einem Sieg verabschieden, vor allen Dingen zu Hause. Die wollen sich nichts vorwerfen lassen. Und, ich weiß nicht, ob die das motiviert. Die wollen vielleicht auch noch die 70 Punkte erreichen. Mit einem Sieg wären sie bei 70 Punkten. Das sieht ja auch ganz nett aus. Also, ja, und ich glaube, die wollen sich eben auch nicht mit so einem schlechten Eindruck aus der Saison verabschieden, nachdem es schon gegen Nürnberg in die Binsen ging. Also, ich glaube nicht, dass Schalke dem was schenken wird. Und dann sind sie tatsächlich wieder von anderen abhängig. Und ich meine, wie gesagt, da reden wir rein theoretisch, je nachdem, wie es läuft, lass mal Fürth gewinnen und Braunschweig richtig auf den Deckel bekommen, dann sind eine Minus-5-Tor-Differenz auch nicht mehr so viel. Also, die haben sogar noch– Chancen klingen immer positiv– Risiken auf Platz 17. Also, ja, es stimmt beides.
Ja, aber man muss da natürlich trotzdem am Ende des Tages noch sagen, du hast es eben schon mal angesprochen, vielleicht dann doch am Ende des Tages ein leicht psychologischer Vorteil, dass die eben Abschiebskampf kennen. In vielen Konsolidationen da.
Ich glaube, nur so war dieser Sieg gegen Dresden möglich. Das war keine spielerische Kunst oder ähnliches. Ja.
Ich würde aber fast sagen, dann gehen wir zu einem Verein, der kennt Abschiebskampf ehrlich gesagt in den letzten Jahren noch nicht so.
Das ist richtig.
Aber hat es vielleicht zum richtigen Zeitpunkt geschafft, seinen Fighting Spirit da zurückzubekommen. Und das ist vor Tünnen und Düsseldorf. Nach dem Sieg heute gegen Elbersberg, wir haben es eben schon mal gesagt, ist es nämlich Platz 15, man ist punktgleich mit Eintracht Braunschweig. 33 zu 50 Tore, also die Offensive lässt trotzdem noch zu wünschen. 11 Siege, 4 Unentschieden, 18 Niederlagen stehen da zu Buche. Vorm Tabelle, da ist man auf Platz 11, weil man hatte eben drei Niederlagen drin, aber eben auch die zwei Siege zuletzt auch dabei, beziehungsweise unterbrochen von einer Liga-Lage zwischenzeitlich. Ja, es war, und das war auf Schalke, also da konnte man als Fortuna Düsseldorf ehrlich gesagt den jeglichen Reich nur verlieren. Marc, ich würde sagen, es ist etwas passiert, was wir nicht dachten, was noch passieren könnte.
Oha, jetzt bin ich aber gespannt.
Ja, nachdem Alex Ende kam und wir haben hier darüber diskutiert, ist das überhaupt der richtige Move? Also was, warum geht man mit Alex Ende? Passt das wirklich so? Dann hat man eben unter ihm das erste Spiel auch direkt wieder verloren, hat aber eben ganz, ganz wichtig den Dreier gegen Dynamo Dresden geholt und jetzt eben auch den Dreier gegen Elbersberg. Und ich würde vorsichtig sagen, dieser Trainerwechsel, der kam vielleicht doch noch zum richtigen Zeitpunkt. Und vielleicht hat man doch noch den richtigen Trainer für diesen Schlussspurt gefunden.
Ich verknallt mir einfach jedes Wortspiel, weil zu einfach. Ja, ich wusste, ich hatte keine klare Meinung zu diesem Trainerwechsel, weil vom Zeitpunkt her fand ich ihn total richtig an sich, weil man gesehen hat, boah, du befreist dich nicht mehr aus dieser Ergebniskrise. Wenn wir jetzt erstmal nur Ergebniskrise unter Markus anfangen. Und dann war für mich aber eben auch die Frage, ist das der richtige Trainer? Und zeitgleich bin ich eben auch nicht der Fan. Das hat ja vielleicht auch die Personalie Alois Schwarz in Münster gezeigt. Ich bin nicht der Fan, immer zu sagen, dann muss es der klassische Feuerwehrmann sein. Das berühmteste Beispiel dahingehend, ich sag mal im deutschen Fußball, ist glaube ich damals der Move gewesen, wo Hoffenheim Julian Nagelsmann zum Trainer gemacht hat. Und der dann mit offensiven Fußball, weil der Kader das damals hergab, das war ja noch, muss man sich vorstellen, Robert Bobby Firmino hat damals im Abschließkampf bei Hoffenheim gespielt. Und da hat er gesagt, na ja, wenn ich einen Bobby Firmino habe, dann sollte ich ja offensiv spielen. Und das hat ja Hoffenheim in der Klasse gehalten. Etwas jüngeres Beispiel ist Sebastian Hoeneß bei Stuttgart. Und, ich weiß gar nicht, war das damals sogar noch eine Personale von Misslint hat? Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher. Ich glaube, nee, kann, nee, natürlich nicht. Das kann gar nicht mehr hinkommen haben. Na ja, was ich sagen will ist, es gibt ja positiv Beispiele dahingehend, dass eine offensive Lösung, die zum Kader durchaus passt, mehr Ergebnisse verspricht, als dieser eher konservative Feuerwehrmann. Das ist irgendwie so dieser Ansatz, den man oft im Kopf hat. Abschließkampf, wir brauchen Sicherheit. Aber vielleicht braucht das die Mannschaft gar nicht. Und vielleicht musst du dann eher in die Stärken der Mannschaft reinspielen und die Stärke von Düsseldorf wird in dieser Saison nicht mehr die defensive werden. Das kannst du vergessen. Also mach doch aus deinem größten Faustpfand der Offensive das Maximale. Und dafür steht ja ein Alexander-Ende. Sicherlich mit einem sehr eigenen Weg. Und da war eben die Frage, ob sein Fußball dazu passt. Aber um Zerriketten herum erst mal zu gucken, dass man einfach mehr Tore schießt als der Gegner, das fand ich logisch irgendwie. Und Stand jetzt funktioniert so einigermaßen. Es funktioniert ja nicht sehr gut, weil jetzt kein Goldenergriff oder so. Aber es funktioniert so einigermaßen. Man ist etwas besser als in den Wochen zuvor. Deswegen steht man jetzt ja überm Strich. Also dementsprechend, ich fühle mich weder bestätigt noch überrascht, weil ich da sehr ergebnisoffen tatsächlich in die Personalie gegangen bin. Und jetzt gilt auch da, man hat es in der eigenen Hand. Es ist das Spiel. Also Düsseldorf gegen Fürth. Hui! Also ganz Druck auf dem Kissen.
Hat es was für Feinschmecker?
Das ist ein bisschen wie in der 1. Liga Pauli Wolfsburg. Das kanntest du vorher ja nicht. Also mittlerweile macht er, glaube ich, eine KI auf den Spielplan, weil einfacher, aber selbst die kann ja nicht voraussehen, wie es teilweise laufen wird dann in der Saison. Das konnte keiner wissen. Und Düsseldorf fürth in Fürth, das wird interessant. Also ich bin sehr gespannt. Natürlich gehen die Mannschaften jetzt mit sehr unterschiedlich Form vorzeichen. Dazu kommen wir ja gleich in diese Partie. Was kann man sagen?
Ja, da gehe ich komplett mit. Ist natürlich eine gute Nachricht, ehrlich gesagt, für alle anderen Mannschaften drum herum, dass es eben dieses direkte Duell noch gibt, weil es kann eben nur...
Einer wird verlieren? Naja, ne, stimmt nicht.
Also in der Theorie kann aber nur eine der beiden Mannschaften 3 Punkte holen.
Ja.
Und das ist ja schon mal per se für viele andere Vereine ein gutes Zeichen. Aber ja, also was dann natürlich das Problem ist, der 5. wird fehlen wegen seiner 5. gelben Karte.
Oh, das hatte ich noch gar nicht mitgeschnitten. Ach du Heilige, das verändert ja alles. Okay, du hast wieder auf das abgestiegen. Vergisst alles, was ich gerade gesagt habe.
Also wenn ich das gar nicht grüe an Thorsten Wiese, der hat das nämlich in die Gruppe geschrieben. Und genau, der hat nämlich in der 64. Spielminute die gelbe Karte bekommen. Wir gucken jetzt gerade nochmal live rein, dass ich jetzt auch wirklich keinen Schwachsinn erzähle. Wir sind gleich so weit, da steht hier natürlich nicht. Wir reden kurz weiter, ich gucke in der Zwischenzeit, ob ich das hier noch finde. Doch, hier steht es auch, zwei Gelbsperren im Endspiel sogar. Also zwei Spieler werden sogar fehlen. Cedric Ditten und Matthias Zimmermann. Fehlen beide mit der gelben Karte.
Noel Futkoy ist im Spiel gegen Hertha um seine Fünfte herumgekommen. Dementsprechend wird der da spielen.
Und das könnte natürlich gerade Matthias Zimmermann auch absolute– die haben doch ja irgendwie einen Spieler mit einer gewissen Steilkraft in Düsseldorf– könnte tatsächlich, trotz der guten Ergebnisse, das könnte tatsächlich nochmal relativ ausschlaggebend sein.
Es ist ausschlaggebend, absolut.
Also wirklich, es gibt keinen ungünstigeren Zeitpunkt, sich eine fünfte Gelbe abzuholen. Kleiner Anforderungsgeschwemmer, man weiß bei Aminia Bielefeld immer noch nicht, hat mal Corvus jetzt am Freitagabend die fünfte Gelbe Karte gesehen oder nicht.
Wie, wo, wie weißt, wie kann man das nicht wissen?
Aber Webseite steht's, bei Kicker steht's nicht, beziehungsweise wurde wieder rausgenommen. Man weiß es nicht, weil man im Spielverlauf tatsächlich auch im Real Life nicht sieht, wann er denn die fünfte Gelbe Karte gesehen haben soll. Es ist sehr amüsant. Ja, ganz toll. Wir werden sehen, am Wochenende. Aber das ist dann auf jeden Fall so ein Punkt, den darf man einfach, wenn wir natürlich die Glaskugel rausholen fürs Wochenende. Ithen ist die Definition, Unterschiedspieler für Fortuna Düsseldorf.
Ithen drin statt nur dabei. Ach du, einer muss ich.
Einer und das der auch. Und das ist für mich tatsächlich der Punkt, wo ich sage so, das kann ja halt am Ende alles nichts gebracht haben, ne? Weil, also was heißt nichts gebracht, aber du hast halt trotzdem, trotzdem, ich weiß, ich wiederhole mich da, leider kein gutes Torverhältnis.
Für Düsseldorf gilt dasselbe für Braunschweig. Wenn es richtig schlecht läuft, kannst du sogar noch auf einem direkten Abschießplatz landen.
Richtig, richtig. Also nehmen wir jetzt mal an, gut, da ist es natürlich wirklich so, müsste mit 5.000 Unterschied gewinnen, sonst wird das nix.
Ne, das stimmt ja nicht. Sie müssen ja nur mit 3.000 gewinnen, weil sich ja zeitgleich Düsseldorfs Torverhältnis verschlechtert. Also ich hab's auch nochmal ausgerechnet, ein Sieg mit 3.000 Unterschied verführt und sie steigen de facto nicht direkt ab, weil dann schieben sie sich ja vor Düsseldorf.
Richtig, richtig, hast du natürlich recht. Du, wir haben ja heute schon unsere Rechenprobleme on und off eher, das ist ganz herrlich. Aber gut, dass wir uns einfach gegenseitig haben und Mathe-Avi hatte ich nicht, nur als drittes Fach. Also, ich muss das nicht können.
Ganz weit von mir weggeschoben, du.
Aber das noch als letztes Wort zu Düsseldorf, wenn wir die Glaskugel gucken, es ist tatsächlich, nachdem sie heute konnte, konnte man erst mal sagen, nach den letzten Wochen guter Ausgangslage, mit dem Blick aufs Personal könnte man sagen, vielleicht doch nicht mehr so die Idealste.
Apropos nicht die idealste Ausgangslage. Eva, wollen wir über die Arminia aus Bielefeld reden?
Ungerne. Richtig ungern. Ich habe so fast gedacht. Es ist Platz 16, man ist abgerutscht auf den 16. Tabellenplatz mit 36 Punkten, 47 zu 50 Toren, 9 Siege, 9 Unentschieden und 15 Niederlagen. Und diese 15. Niederlage, kam am Freitagabend gegen Kaiserslautern. Man ist in der Formtabelle auch auf Platz 15, weil man in den letzten fünf Spielen eben nur einen Sieg holen konnte gegen Preußen Münster. Es war ein 1-1 gegen Bochum dabei, wo man aus mehreren Gründen sagen muss, das muss man eigentlich gewinnen, aufgrund des Spielverlaufs, aufgrund der Art und Weise, wie das 1-1 fällt und tatsächlich auch aufgrund der Tatsache, dass zumindest mal ein– ich glaube, wir sind uns alle einig– sehr klarer Elfmeter nicht gegeben wurde. Hilft alles nichts. Nichtsdestotrotz darfst du am Freitagabend gegen Kaiserslautern niemals so auftreten. Früh muss Maxi Bauer ausgewechselt werden. Maximilian Großer kommt dafür rein. Man kassiert einen Stroh-dummen Elfmeter.
Das ist wirklich der Wahnsinn. Da müssen wir mal kurz drüber reden. Das ist ja wirklich die Definition von gebrauchter Tag in diesen ersten Minuten des Spiels. Also wie Handwerker da in– ich weiß es gar nicht, was es am Ende war, in den er da reingerauscht ist.
Der hat beiden Schorle getrunken.
So nämlich. Hattest du dir auch absolut verdient. Genau so macht man es. Hefe. Hefe. Ich habe die wirklich als unbeteiligt, ich habe die Hände über den Kopf zusammengeschnallt. Wie kann man das machen?
Ja. Es war, also zusätzlich auch, war ja Daniel Jara, Cheftrainer für die Partie, bei Mitch Cleon nach dem Spiel gegen den VfL Bochen, die rote Karte gesehen hat. Einfach vielleicht kurz meine zwei Cents dazu. Natürlich sollte man niemanden, und das schiebe ich schon mal vorweg, er hat auch niemanden als geisteskrank bezeichnet, sondern die Situation, in der er abgefiffen wurde, als geisteskrank bezeichnet. Das Wort sollte man nicht nutzen, es ist eh ballistisch. Das sollten alle wissen. Und das finde ich auch nicht in Ordnung. Trotzdem könnte man eventuell ein bisschen nachfragen, wie viel Fingerspitzengefühl von Tobias Stieler in dem Moment an den Tag gelegt wurde, dafür dann direkt die rote Karte zu zeigen. Weil es ist, also die Frage ist, und das würde ich Tobias Stieler tatsächlich unterstellen, hätte er mit Kniet gesagt, er findet es unglücklich, in dem Moment abzufeifen, ob Tobias Stieler dann eventuell auch trotzdem die rote Karte gezeigt hätte.
Und ich sag mal so, Pele Wollitz und ich. Ein Satz, der mit Pele Wollitz und ich anfängt, ist immer ein komischer. Aber wir stimmen nicht oft überein. Aber da musste ich ihm Recht geben, weil er das jetzt, hatte er das nach seinem eigenen Spiel, glaube ich, angesprochen oder davor, wo er nämlich mit Kniet in Schutz genommen hat und gesagt hat, also da wollte er quasi das Größefass aufmachen, Fingerspitzengefühl von Trainern, bei Trainern, von Schiedsrichtern oder auch Spielern, weil er sagt, da ist maximal Druck auf dem Kessel. So, für Bielefeld geht es um alles. Und wenn das der Satz, der sehr gefallen ist, dann empfindet er es als eben unglücklich und als fehlendes Fingerspitzengefühl, wenn der Schiedsrichter so entscheidet. Und da würde ich absolut mitgehen. Wenn es eine persönliche Beleidigung oder ähnliches gewesen wäre, dann brauchen wir nicht lange drüber schnacken, dann ist das zu viel. Wäre immer noch irgendwie zu erklären gewesen, aber nicht zu entschuldigen. Und so empfinde ich es als drüber. Und ich glaube, da gab es auch die längere Geschichte, dass man eh bei Stieler nicht das Gefühl hatte, dass er sonderlich kommunikativ aufgestellt ist. Viel verschiedenster.
Also ich muss es tatsächlich sagen.
Ich möchte das auch noch mal betonen, dass ich nachhinein hatte, ich da mitbekommen, was der Satz waren, was so, ach, darum ging es echt? Ja krass, okay, das ist tatsächlich wahnsinnig wenig. Und da beachtet man nicht, um was es da gerade für Bielefeld geht.
Naja, und mit Kniet ist auch nicht auf ihn zugestürmt. Ja, also auch das könnte ich verstehen, wenn er, also gerade wenn mit Kniet auf mich zugestürmt kommen würde, würde ich auch erstmal weglaufen, ehrlich gesagt. Aber das ist einfach, also, bei so einem wichtigen Spiel auch seine Art und Weise hinterher zu kommunizieren. Weil Stieler hat sich selber zum Beispiel zum Verhalten nicht geäußert. Mit Kniet hat direkt danach am Mikrofon gesagt, ey, ich darf es so nicht sagen, es tut mir total leid, darf mir so nicht passieren. Und ich finde es dann irgendwie schon ein bisschen belastend in dem Moment, dass ein Trainer dann mehr Reflektion zeigt, als der Schiedsrichter, der ihm die rote Karte gegeben hat. Aber gut, das wollte ich einmal noch sagen. Nichtsdestotrotz muss man einfach sagen, du hast, glaube ich, in diesem Spiel noch mal sehr deutlich gemerkt, dass es eben gerade im Abschluss vorne an Qualität, also angeblich, ich sage mal, also ich hatte noch nie in meinem Leben ein Spiel, wo Stadionwahrnehmung und ein Blick auf die Statistiken danach auseinandergegangen sind. Also ich weiß nicht, wo ich war, als es die 20 Torschüsse gab, anscheinend nicht anwesend, aber man muss auch da sein, die Qualität der Torschüsse war trotz einem X-Golz-Wert von 1,54, was halt bei 20 Torschüssen immer noch verschwunden ist.
Das muss man eben sagen, das stücke sich dann in sehr wenig auf auf einmal.
Ja, doch durchaus sehr belassend und man muss einfach sagen, nach dem Sieg gegen Münster war ich ja auch vorsichtig positiv und man muss auch sagen, ich betone das gerne nochmal, ich fand auch, das Bochum-Spiel hat von der Leistung dann her gepasst. Dass Bielefeld auswärts schwach ist, ist auch keine neue Info. Aber die Art und Weise, und das ist wirklich was, ich habe hier in der letzten Sendung die Mannschaft, den Verein in Schutz genommen. Die Art und Weise, wie man Freitag aufgetreten ist, war für viele, viele Bielefeld-Fans eine ganz böse Rückbesinnung an diese Saison vor drei Jahren. Als man das Gefühl hatte, der Mannschaft auf dem Platz ist nicht so ganz klar, worum es geht. Ich glaube auch hier, dass Arminia im Gegensatz vielleicht zu ein, zwei anderen Vereinen den psychologischen Vorteil hat, dass man schon mal mit dem Rücken zur Wand stand und damals halt eben um einige schlimmer vor zwei Jahren.
Du, der Vorteil heißt Theater-BSC.
Nein, ich mache hier gar keine Vorteile mehr. Es meinten auch alle, der Vorteil ist Erster, Erste, Kaiserslautern, weil guck mal, wie die spielen und ja.
Fair, fair.
Ich meine, für den FCK freut es mich. Die haben nach, also generell, man hat irgendwie nach drei Spielen, die man verloren hat und absolut bodenloser Stimmung zu Hause eben da, dann nochmal die Fans mitnehmen können. Oh gut, es war auch, also liebe Grüße an die ganzen ersten FCK-Fans, die ich getroffen habe, die waren alle sehr nett und meinten so, hey, wenigstens euer Support war klasse. Und ich so, hm, danke, Zupi, das ist immer schön zu hören.
Ich hab freigesprochen und viele Bilder benutzt.
Ja, genau, ich dachte, das ist, hm, stets bemüht, toll. Aber das war, also...
Was meinst du, also du sagtest jetzt, man hatte das Gefühl, dass die nicht wissen, worum es geht. Das kann ich mir als Außenstehender nicht richtig vorstellen, bei dieser Truppe, die gefühlt nur über Mentalität kommt. Ist es vielleicht auch am Ende, man steht ja jetzt schon, also... Bielefeld steht jetzt relativ schon lange da unten jetzt wieder richtig drin. Und, ja, es gab zum Beispiel auch das Spiel in Elbersberg, wo man wirklich, wo es ein starkes Stück war, aber wo man auch, ich hab das Gefühl, es geht auch langsam wirklich die Kraft aus. Also, weil, glaubst du, war das ein Kopfding, war das ein Kraftding. Ich würde als Außenstehender erst mal naiv darauf tippen, keiner hat an dem Tag so richtig zu 100 Prozent gefunden, dann weißt du eben doch, worum es geht, verkrampft es vielleicht, ich weiß es nicht. Aber mir würde es sehr fern liegen, wie gesagt, als Außenstehender, dieser Mannschaft fehlende Mentalität zu unterstellen.
Ja, also in der Theorie schon. Es ist halt natürlich schon einfach so am Ende des Tages, es gab eben auch große Diskussionen in der Biegelfeldbubble auf Blue Sky, so was ich mitbekommen habe. Weil man halt aber schon irgendwie, also manchmal hatte man dann schon das Gefühl, so die richtige, also dieser Fighting Spirit, der im Spiel gegen Münster da war, wo du trotz Rückstand irgendwie das Gefühl hattest, okay, hier wird jetzt alles trotzdem dafür getan, zu gewinnen. Das hat mir halt einfach nach dem 1-0 gefehlt. Weil klar, das ist natürlich auch bitter, wenn du dann auch nicht einen klassischen Trainer in der Seitenlinie hast. Du musst früh wechseln, du kriegst früh diesen Elber. Das ist alles schwierig, aber trotzdem musst du dich halt fragen, ob du in dem Spiel alles gegeben hast. Und das Einzige, was ich da positiv sehe, ist, dass Jonas Kersgen als Torhüter nach dem Spiel gesagt hat, brauchen wir nicht schönreden. Das war unter aller Sau, weil ehrlich gesagt, zum Beispiel nach dem 1-1 gegen Nürnberg war schon so, dass man ja, wir haben ja per se nicht schlecht gespielt, wo ich mir dachte, ja, also es war schon einer der schlechteren Heimspiele. Also das einzige Positive, was ich sehe, dass man zu Hause bisher, bis auf das Nürnberg-Spiel vielleicht in den letzten Wochen keinen richtigen Totalausfall hatte zu Hause. Also die Ausfälle, die man hatte, das war das Auswärtsspiel in Kaiserslautern, das war das Auswärtsspiel in Karlsruhe. Und eben das Auswärtsspiel in Elbersberg. Da muss man halt einfach schon sagen, wo man sich im Zweifel auch das Torverhältnis leider noch mal so ein bisschen in Anführungszeichen versaut hat. Minus drei ist immer noch voll in Ordnung. Aber das würde ich halt sagen, es war sowieso so, dass die Auswärtsspiele eher das Problem waren. Und ich glaube, zu Hause gegen Hertha, da kommt dann schon nochmal eine andere Energie irgendwie mit und muss aber auch. Also das ist vielleicht einfach schon mal mein, ich nutze das jetzt nochmal als Ampel. Es muss halt am Sonntag genau das sein, was die letzten zwei Jahre gegolten hat. Es geht nur zusammen. Also es bringt überhaupt nichts, wenn am Sonntag jetzt bei jedem Ballverlust irgendwie ausgefiffen wird, sondern wir müssen wirklich schauen, dass wir das, was diese Mannschaft die letzten zwei Jahre ausgezeichnet hat und das ist eigentlich eben nie aufzugeben, immer wieder an sich zu glauben, immer wieder auch in Kombination mit den Fans, da alles rauszuhauen. Und das geht am Sonntag nur zusammen. Und also ganz ehrlich, wer am Sonntag dann nur hingeht, um am Ende des Spiels zu sagen, so ich hab's immer gesagt, der Knie hat, der ist es nicht, dann bleibt doch bitte einfach zu Hause, die Karten wird man los.
Fair enough. Ich glaube, um noch meine drei Cents zu dem Lauternspiel, ich glaube, was man da fernab jeder Mentalität und so weiter noch mal gesehen hat, ist, also wenn Bielefeld in der Liga bleibt, müssen sie nächstes Jahr definitiv an der Kreativabteilung arbeiten. Das Kriieren von Torchancen fällt dieser Mannschaft aus eigenem Ballbesitz heraus einfach immens schwer. Du hast bis auf Mumulu gefühlt keinen einzigen Spieler, der einen 1 gegen 1 auflösen kann. Die letzten Pässe, da hast du auch nicht die klaren Spieler für. Ja, ein Wölk kann es eventuell mal. Manchmal kann es auch von aus dem Halbraum heraus auch so jemand wie Rochelt. Aber dir fehlt fußballerische Klasse. Ja, die sind alle Mentalitätsspieler. Ja, die laufen alle sehr, sehr viel und sind sehr gut in Zweikampf und so weiter. Das hat ja sehr viel von Bielefeld in den letzten Jahren ausgemacht, um Gottes Willen. Und das ist natürlich auch die teuerste Spielklasse, quasi Spielerklasse, solche Spieler zu bekommen. Du wirst aber nächstes Jahr nicht drum herumkommen. Du brauchst ein paar Zocker mit dem Team, weil sonst läufst du dich irgendwann auch stumpf. Du brauchst einfach irgendwie Ideen. Und das hast du dann gemerkt gegen Lautern, nachdem sie geführt haben und so und auch wussten, dass Bielefeld muss, dass Bielefeld nicht so richtig kann. Also ich finde, das gehört noch zur Geschichte dieser Mannschaft dazu.
Genau. Und das ist ja auch das, was ich vor zwei Wochen gesagt habe. Ich kann da weiterhin Michael Mutzel keinen so richtigen Vorwurf machen, das nicht im Sommer schon angegangen zu haben, weil diese Mannschaft komplett zu zerreißen, wäre halt auch, also das würde halt auch komplett schief gehen können, weil wir haben eben auch gesehen, was passiert bei Komplettumbrüchen. Das kann eben in beide Richtungen gehen. Und ich weiß es nicht, ob man, also wie gesagt, man hört eben auch nicht nur Positives über so ein paar Umgänge, vielleicht mit Knien, mit seinen Spielern.
Ich sag das aber da auch gerne. Dann wirst du aber selten von einem Trainer haben.
Und ich sag das aber trotzdem auch gerne hier nochmal. Niemand ist größer als der Verein. Und also ich weiß dann halt immer nicht, ihr habt dann halt, ja, das sind Spieler, die standen im Pokalfinale, sind aufgestiegen, haben halt für ihre erste, zweite Saison vielleicht eine durchschnittliche gespielt. Aber ich frag mich dann also, ohne mit Knien, ständet ihr ehrlich gesagt auch nicht da, wo ihr dort steht und hättet nicht das Schaufenster bekommen, ehrlich gesagt. Und ich gehe weiterhin davon aus, dass da wird sich niemand im Sommer hinsetzen und sagen, jo, weiter so, weil das war nach der ersten Drittliga-Saison auch nicht der Fall, wo man fast abgestiegen ist. Aber man darf halt auch einfach nicht vergessen, wo Bielefeld aus den letzten drei Jahren herkommt und dass man da nicht direkt wieder das finanzielle Risiko geht. Das sage ich auch gerne nochmal, wem das nicht bewusst war. Und wir haben hier so oft darüber gesprochen, wie schwierig der Transfermarkt ist. Und ich meine, Marc, du kannst da von Lieds singen, wie selbst Vereine, die sagen, auf dem Papier haben wir einen guten Kader und sehr gute Einzelspieler, die das im Endeffekt halt nichts bringt, wenn du das nicht konstant auf den Platz bekommst. Und deshalb, ja, individuelle Klasse ist nicht immer der Schlüssel zum Erfolg. Aber sonst unterspreche ich alles, was du gesagt hast. Und was machen wir dann jetzt? Also, von individueller Klasse und Hertha BSC. Wie ist da jetzt die perfekte Überleitung zu unserem letzten Verein?
Die Überleitung ist, dass Hertha BSC vielleicht genau wegen dieser individuellen Klasse dieses Spiel gegen Fürth gewonnen hat. Denn anders ist das nicht zu erklären, dass Fürth dieses Spiel im Olympiastadion am Sonntag verliert. Vielleicht mal kurz zur Ausgangslage. Die Spielvereinigung Fürth, die ja sich sehr darum bemüht, dass es nicht mehr Greuther Fürth heißt, steht mit 34 Zählern jetzt auf Rang 17. Zwei Punkte hinter Bielefeld und drei hinter Düsseldorf, so wie Braunschweig. Dazu hat man das klar schwächste Torverhältnis. Also ein direkter Klassenhalt, das schiebe ich mal vorweg, der ist schon sehr unwahrscheinlich. Das muss man so sagen. Man müsste sich am ehesten in die Relegation retten. Da ist man eben zum einen davon abhängig, dass man gewinnt und zum anderen, dass Bielefeld eben nicht gewinnt. Ich glaube, da muss Bielefeld gewinnen. Also wenn sie einen Punkt holen, dann reicht es schon wieder nicht aufgrund der Tor-Differenz. Also man ist ja jetzt wirklich sehr abhängig von anderen Teams. Zu dem Spiel jetzt gegen Hertha, ja, ich glaube, das ist, also es war eine unverdiente Niederlage. Machen wir es mal ganz kurz. Hertha sieht irgendwann in Person von Josep Brejkalo eine sehr unglückliche rote Karte, die okay war aufgrund der Situation, aber sie ist für Brejkalo persönlich sehr unglücklich. Es ist auch sehr unglücklich, dass er jetzt schon wieder eine rote Karte sieht für etwas, was er nicht selber verbrochen hat. Naja, passt zur Hertha-Saison, darum soll es nicht gehen. Ab diesem Zeitpunkt war Düsseldorf, Düsseldorf, Fürth ein Mann mehr. Vorher war das Spiel wirklich nicht gut von beiden Seiten. Es gab eine Chance von Futkoi, die er wahrscheinlich sogar reinmachen muss, auch wenn er sich da sehr um die eigene Achse drehen muss. Und dann fehlt oft dann die Orientierung. Aber trotzdem kann man sagen, bei der Form, die er hat, kann er schon mal machen. Abseits dessen war es von beiden Mannschaften nichts. Und dann baut sich mit der Zeit natürlich, weil du ein Mann mehr bist, Druck auf. Du versuchst, mehr nach vorne zu gehen, weil du irgendwie auch musst. Und dann kassierst du aber ein Gegentor. Das hat mit Profifußball nichts zu tun. Das war wirklich unfassbar. Jetzt kann man sagen, ja, Kenneth Eichhorn, dass der mit 16 Jahren dieses Dribbling überhaupt wagt. Das spricht dann wieder für die Klasse und den Mut dieses 16-Jährigen. Und das ist irre. Auf der anderen Seite stehen da 5 Vierter und tu nix. Tu einfach gar nix. Das ist unfassbar gewesen. Da siehst du einfach, dass Viert, also Heiko Vogel hat ein paar Dinge geschafft, aber diesen defensiven Schlendrian und diese unerklärlichen Dinge, die da passieren, die hat er auch eher nicht dieser Mannschaft austreiben können. Das zweite Gegentor, was dann ja quasi durch das Spiel so ein bisschen entscheidet, das musst du in der Entstehung besser verteidigen. Da darf Karbovnik und Co. einfach zu viel machen, dass dieser Schuss von Cuisance dann kommt, wie er kommt. Ja, das ist dann bitter, aber du musst es in der Entstehung besser verteidigen. Du kommst durch Futtkoll sogar noch mal ran. Aber das große Problem waren an dem Tag zum einen, dass du defensiv zwei, drei Mal wirklich amateurhaft aussaust und dir das nicht erlauben kannst zu diesem Zeitpunkt der Saison. Das geht nicht. Und das andere ist, dass du vorne wirklich atemberaubend schwach warst im Abschluss. Futtkoll hätte eigentlich noch über sein Tor hinaus zwei Tore machen müssen. Hurgotha hatte eine sehr gute Chance. Felix Klaus hatte gefühlt vier gute Chancen. Der eingewechselte Hiegel hatte eine gute Chance. Ja, Hertha hat sich in alles dann irgendwo heroisch reingeworfen. Und dann kann man das aus Hertha-Sicht mit Wille und ähnlichem erklären. Aus Vierter Sicht eine maximal unnötige Niederlage, die eben wehtut, weil selbst wenn du einfach nur einen Punkt mitnimmst, hast du eben die Möglichkeit, dass selbst wenn Bielefeld unentschieden spielt, du vor sie ziehen kannst. Also selbst wenn du einen Punkt hättest, du dir eine bessere Aushangslage für den letzten Spieltag geschaffen. Jetzt bei diesem Spiel dann eben gegen Düsseldorf, wo der maximale Druck drauf liegt. Man hat so gespielt, dass irgendwann der Support eingestellt wurde bei Viert, weil das ist irgendwie bitter gewesen, weil man hat ja mit der Truppe schon angesehen, dass sie wollte. Sie hat versucht, aber natürlich ist man da nicht mehr rein rational als Fan. Die haben sich danach auch ordentlich was anhören dürfen aus der Gäste-Kurve. Die haben mir fast leidgetan, weil ich so dachte, naja, eigentlich hat ja nur das Tor gefehlt. Aber du differenzierst an dem Zeitpunkt als Fan natürlich auch nicht mehr so krass. Und ich bin sehr gespannt. Auch da glaube ich, dass sich viele darauf besinnen werden, ey, Heimspiel, letzte Chance. Die tun auch mal alles dafür. Alle stellen sich hinter den Verein und wir supporten. Aber da hast du wieder so einen Bruch gemerkt. Am Ende mache ich mir schon sehr viel Sorgen um Fird, weil sie am instabilsten von allen wirken.
Ja, man muss halt sagen, in dem Sinne muss man die Fans fast ein bisschen in Schutz auch nehmen, weil du hattest jetzt das zweite Spiel ja eigentlich in Folge, wo du sagst, naja, das musst du gewinnen im Frankendorbi gegen Nürnberg. Hast du das 1-1? Nürnberg mehr Torschüsse, aber führt da eigentlich die höhere Qualität an Torschüssen. Dann wird unter der Woche bekannt, Brandy Mio Gotra verlässt den Verein nach gefühlt 120 Jahren jetzt auch mal. Etwas, das man, wenn man ehrlich ist, sich ja auch langsam aber sicher angedeutet hat, dass der nicht den Gang mit in die dritte Liga geht, sollte der anstehen, war klar, ob das kommunikativ jetzt der richtige Zeitpunkt war.
So wie ich es rückbekommen habe, war es so, dass das einfach zu sehr schon nach außen gedrungen ist und dann wahrscheinlich der Verein, das quasi mit die Flucht nach vorne angetreten ist.
Genau. Also es war jetzt auch gar kein Vorwurf an Rukgota oder Führt. Es ist immer die Frage, wer da halt Informationen durchsticht. Aber ich glaube, da können viele Vereine ein Lied von singen. Und dann ist es halt wirklich einfach. Und das meine ich mit dem, die Fans in Schutz nehmen. Du hattest eben die Spiele gerade in der Rückrunde, wo du vielleicht nicht unbedingt die bessere Mannschaft warst, wo du trotzdem die Punkte mitgenommen hast.
Das stimmt.
Aber du kannst halt zu diesem Zeitpunkt der Saison wahrscheinlich einfach nicht mehr sagen so, ja, hey, ist doch alles top. Hey, ist doch super. Und man muss dann halt auch sagen…
Nee, nee, das wollte ich ja sagen. Die Differenz-Jugend bleibt dann irgendwann einfach auf der Strecke.
Und weil du halt eben sagen musst, hey, wenn das Spiel 0-0 ausgeht, okay, ist immer noch nicht ideal, weil dir vielleicht vorne einfach die Qualität fehlt. Aber wie du eben auch schon gesagt hast, die Art und Weise, wie vor allem das 0 zu 1 fällt, das darf halt nicht passieren. Und das siehst du als Fan natürlich auch. Und das ist eben, glaube ich, das Tragische. Und da muss man einfach sagen, Fjord war so wie meine Top-Pflanzen bei mir zu Hause, wo ich immer zwischendurch, also ich besitze jetzt wieder keine, ich hatte mal eine, wo ich immer so dreimal dachte, kommt sie noch mal wieder? Und am Ende war es so ein sehr, war es ein Trauerspiel. Sag ich wie es ist, war es einfach ein Trauerspiel, was da übrig lief. Und man muss jetzt leider sagen, also das lag an meiner nicht vorhandenen grünen Daumenaktivität. Und bei Fjord muss man einfach sagen, das reicht eben auch qualitativ einfach nicht. Da ist halt, sie haben den kreativen Spieler mit Noel Furtkoy. Also das ist ja trotzdem immer noch, der hat, also ohne Noel Furtkoy, wer führt, glaube ich, noch um einiges. Also da wäre der Abstieg schon sehr viel früher statt. Aber man muss schon sagen, es fällt einem wirklich, wirklich schwer, trotz der Sachen, bei denen wir gerade über Düsseldorf gesprochen haben, wie das reichen soll. Und auch, also selbst wenn sie es noch schaffen in die Relegation, also auch da wissen wir noch nicht, wen wir da von unten kommen.
Nö, bunte Tüte.
Absolut bunte Tüte. Also das wird für viele Vereine schwierig, weil anders als in der Ausstiegsrelegation, ist in der Abstiegsrelegation tatsächlich meistens der Drittligist im Vorteil. Also eben auch viel über die Qualität der beiden Ligen aussagt. Aber ja, ich sehe tatsächlich und ich glaube da, also das ist auch was da, da wird uns Michi Fischer auch bei unterstützen. Man muss, also wir haben bei Magdeburg und Dresden gesagt, nach der Saison wäre es auch nicht unverdient, drin zu bleiben nach der Art und Weise, wie man sich entwickelt hat. Bei Fürth muss man fast sagen, ja, sie haben sich zwischendurch nochmal hochgekämpft, aber über jetzt 33 Spieltage gezogen, ist die Frage, ob ein Klassenerhalt, vor allem ein direkter Klassenerhalt, in dem Falle überhaupt verdient wäre.
Da ist mal eine klare Antwort, nein. Also für mich wäre das ein verdienter Absteiger. Aber so wie es bei Bielefeld usw. gilt, du hast jetzt diesen einen Spieltag. Du hast diesen einen Spieltag, du hast ein Heimspiel. Du spielst gegen eine Mannschaft, die selber nicht das perfekte mentale Gerüst für so ein Spiel hat, mit Düsseldorf. Wie gesagt, du bist sehr von anderen Teams abhängig. Das steht ja außer Frage. Vor allen Dingen halt einfach von Bielefeld. Du musst also alles anderes eigentlich egal. Du musst halt gucken, was Bielefeld dann macht. Aber du musst erstmal deine Hausaufgaben machen, um dir ja nichts vorwerfen zu können. Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass es möglich ist, dass Fird dieses Spiel gewinnt und trotzdem absteigt, weil Bielefeld was holt gegen Hertha, das glaube ich, ist definitiv möglich. Wie Hertha die letzten Wochen auftritt, also... Da kurz der Hertha-Talk. Also Hertha ist seit Wochen richtig schlecht. Das einzig gute Spiel, und das ist dann auch noch das, was man verliert, war gegen Kiel. Das darf man auf keinen Fall verlieren, so. Das war wirklich ein Freak-Spiel dahingehend. Aber alles andere ist wirklich schlecht. Und ich sehe bei Hertha nicht, dass das am letzten Spieltag aus dem Nichts kommt, diese Truppe wirkt geschlagen, im Sinne von auch, dass da richten sich viele Blicke schon in den Sommer. Viele werden aufhören, werden gehen, aus verschiedensten Gründen. Da ist kein großer Spirit mehr drin. Das hat ja auch dieses Spiels gegen Fürth gezeigt. Solange das Elf gegen Elfer und Hertha quasi auch mehr Ballbesitzung zu hatte, war das ein grausiges Fußballspiel. Und dann gewinnst du dieses Spiel irgendwie, weil du effizient bist und hinten noch dein Kadaver dazwischen geworfen bekommst. Aber, ja, ganz ehrlich, es ist so. Ich sehe die Blitzheilung nicht vor dem Spiel gegen Bielefeld und deswegen muss sich Bielefeld da was ausrechnen. Du kannst gegen diese Hertha definitiv was holen. Und wenn es nur ein Punkt ist.
Du hast ja eben deine Prognose abgegeben, dass du sagst, die Tabelle bleibt so bei den Aussteigern. Da ist der Pool ein bisschen kleiner. Würdest du dich sogar an eine– also ich habe eben Power-Rankings so ein bisschen angesprochen. Es ist hier natürlich schon eine durchaus andere Ausgangslage. Aber was würdest du denn in Bezug auf das Abstiegskonglomerator unten sagen?
Ja, habe ich natürlich parallel so ein bisschen drüber nachgedacht. Also ich sage, dass Magdeburg und Dresden sind durch. Ich glaube, dass Düsseldorf nicht absteigt. Die werden das irgendwie hinbekommen gegen Fürth. Und wenn es irgendwie ein Punkt ist, ich sage jetzt, mein Call ist, dass Bielefeld mindestens einen Punkt holt gegen Hertha und Braunschweig aber auf Schalke verliert. Und deswegen landet Braunschweig auf dem Religationsplatz und Bielefeld rutscht noch auf Rang 15. Punktgleich aber Tor-Differenz.
Du, wenn das so ausgeht, kannst du dir schon mal, der nächste Eisbecher geht auf mich.
Stark!
Das kannst du dir schon mal merken. Was sagst denn du?
Du bist ja beteiligt, das ist immer schwierig.
Du, ich habe eben schon nichts gesagt und deshalb sage ich einfach nichts mehr.
Total fair, es ist total fair.
Ich habe mir die Grube nicht gegraben, eben du dir schon. Das ist richtig.
Das ist richtig. Gut, ich würde sagen, hast du noch was?
Ja, genau. Ich wollte einfach nur sagen, ich wünsche, auch wenn ich nicht unbeteiligt bin, trotzdem allen Teams da drunter ganz, ganz viel Kraft für den letzten Spieltag. Ja, es ist nur Fußball, aber ja, wir wissen trotzdem, es ist manchmal die schönste, manchmal die schlimmste Nebensache der Welt. Und da deshalb einfach schon mal passt auf euch auf, am nächsten Sonntag, wo immer ihr auch unterwegs seid, habt vielleicht was Schönes nach 17.30 geplant. Und ich wünsche natürlich euch nicht allen das Erreichen des Saisonziels, weil das geht dann leider nicht so ganz auf. Aber ja, haltet gut durch. Und ich glaube, es wird noch eine Abschlussfolge geben, aber ich sag trotzdem schon mal auch, ihr Marques, hat mir sehr, sehr viel Spaß gemacht mit dir diese Saison. Und ich fand das auch sehr cool. Und da gerne auch, also wenn ihr Feedback nicht nur zu der Folge habt, aber natürlich auch generell zu dem Format. Es hat mir sehr Spaß gemacht, zwischendurch auch mal diese zwei Erfolgen einzustreuen, weil das, glaube ich, auch ja für sowohl für die Hörer erinnern als auch für uns nochmal immer ein guter Feedback-Kreis irgendwie war.
Total. Ich drücke schon mal aufs Outro und gebe das genauso zurück, Eva. Das hat mir ganz großen Spaß gemacht, auch in diesem neuen Modus jetzt mit unseren Allstars. Sehr, sehr geile Geschichte. Ich habe das Gefühl, das ist eine richtig eingestrohene Truppe draus geworden. Ich möchte gar keinen verlieren jetzt durch den Abstieg. Mach das mal nicht, ey. Das ist eine Katastrophe. Naja, vielen lieben Dank fürs Zuhören. Vielen lieben Dank für die Unterstützung in Kommentaren in Form von Spenden. Das wissen wir alles sehr zu schätzen. Und wie gesagt, Saisonrückblick wird es geben. Bis dahin, machts gut. Ciao, ciao.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.